tag 2 auf der tief station am klinikum
fulda dieses mal war wieder nachtschicht
dabei es war schön zu sehen wie die
pflegerinnen und pfleger wie das team
gemeinsam funktioniert wie schätze
gemacht werden wie man sich unterstützt
wie man was rein reist jemand hilft wie
einfach die stimmung trotz all der
ernsthaftigkeit hier auf stationen
einigermaßen locker ist aber dann haben
wir notfall erlebt und sofort gesehen
wie das team professionell fokussiert
konzentriert vorgegangen ist und die
patienten zu helfen und dabei kamen
dieser notfallwagen hier zum einsatz
hier sieht man den bildschirm der die
vitalzeichen zeigt man sieht ein ersatz
atemgerät ein defibrillator eine tasche
mit sämtlichen medikamenten für notfälle
für intubieren und so weiter und eine
eine sauerstoffflasche
dieser rang an zum einsatz wir waren
live dabei und das könnte sich jetzt
anschauen
die korona krise am höhepunkt täglich
neue traurige rekordzahlen in den
krankenhäusern
am klinikum fulda ist die kurve die
intensivstation voll belegt die
belastung für pfleger und ärzte hoch
bild durfte sie tag und nacht begleiten
20 uhr 30 nachtschicht auf der
intensivstation pflegerin antoni will
gerade mit der routine maßnahmen
beginnen medikamente check umlagern der
patienten
doch dann der schreckmoment bei einem
coup patienten 71 jahre stimmt etwas mit
der atmung nicht
ja vielleicht hat ja die explorations
kassette kaputt große wirkung mit rein
und helfen die rund 1000 autos und alles
klar also die haben jetzt gerade
beatmungs probleme bei dem patienten
deswegen müssen wir gerade einmal die
das beatmungsgerät noch einmal neu
aufrüsten und dazu haben wir hier
draußen noch und notfallwagen stehen im
einsatz beatmungsgerät genau falls es so
nicht klappt hallo codenamen wir
wechseln gerade noch mal was an den
beatmungsgerät ausfiel brauchen keine
angst haben vor der tür der notfallwagen
hinter der tür muss der 71-jährige über
fünf minuten ohne die unterstützung des
beatmungsgeräts auskommen er hat
sichtlich probleme genug luft zu
bekommen sein brustkorb hebt sich nur
leicht und dafür hastig die
sauerstoffsättigung im blut sinkt und
sinkt da kommen also alles angestellt
verläuft alles ist gut gelaufen der
notfallwagen kommt nicht zum einsatz
aber was war der grund ja genau wir
vermuten dass er weiterhin ziemlich
starke hustet hat deswegen haben jetzt
gerade einmal diese kassette
ausgetauscht und dafür müssen wir das
beatmungsgerät einer komplett neu decken
nennt man was man macht so eine art
vorkontrolle das gerät zeigt sich ob
alles mit der gasversorgung stimmt am
gerät das er bei den dann auch wieder
richtig beatmet ist von rücker schicht
also keine spur
die nachtschicht auf der intensivstation
unterscheidet sich kaum von der am tag
die gleiche personalstärke der gleiche
intensive pflegeaufwand und immer die
bereitschaft schnell eingreifen zu
müssen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren